note of recycling and cleaning up you
know a lot of you may have taken your
Christmas tree down right after
Christmas maybe you wait though until
the new year to get that out of your
house don't just throw it away though
you can recycle it for a good cause
joining us live this morning from Sunset
Park it's Tara Pike chair of the
Southern Nevada Christmas tree recycling
program and unlv's sustainability
coordinator Terence good to see you once
again this morning
hi good morning good morning Happy New
Year as well let's talk about the
recycling program been around for a long
long time why is it so important for
people to you know recycle their tree
instead of just tossing it on the corner
well when you toss it on the corner it
ends up in the landfill and it has no
beneficial use after that and when you
take it to one of our 30 drop sites uh
we chip it up and we use that mulch that
chippings in the landscape to conserve
water and control dust so instead of
making it just rot in a landfill let's
get it into good use absolutely this is
a program that will go until January
15th as we've talked about earlier this
has become a has been a popular program
for a long long time how many trees do
you usually get during a holiday season
we averaged about 15 500 trees each year
our biggest year was uh just over 20 000
trees love to see that now uh if you go
back out to your live shot we've already
seen him to see once again your friend
that's with you that is helping with the
mulch creation project with the with the
valley here who who's with you right
there
this is Deacon and he
he trees
um as just like a treat in his diet you
know they normally eat hay but
he uh he likes them each year to have a
couple you want he's looking forward to
some breakfast right now he's earned it
after the holiday season it's time to
have a sweet treat himself those trees
seem to do the trick uh Tara thank you
very much for joining us this morning
Deacon thank you as well uh good luck
with the recycling program and uh of
course we have the 30 sites listed at
8newsnow.com Kara have a good morning